allons-y je veux vous
parler d'affaires ce n'est pas grand-
chose voulez-vous kidnapper ça doit être
riche en puant La sécurité est un petit plus
maintenant nous allons le faire nous le faisons maintenant
J'aime les pantoufles de peignoir et ce n'est pas
trop un problème  et téléphone si vous dites à
la police où je suis je vous donnerai la moitié de
la rançon et une maison en Suisse
et deviendrai trop personnel il vous rentrera dans la
tête vous savez que ce que vous faites est
complètement stupide si vos gens ne le font pas
payer bientôt alors je ne peux pas répondre pour mon
peuple
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu as fait et ton
frère merci bouche fermée d'
accord foutez le camp maintenant
quelque chose de grand buzz à propos de la chose la plus
importante est où nous planquons l'
argent
les flics vont comprendre qu'il y a un
tas de branleurs locaux et ils
vont nous clouer à plat savoir quoi pas forcé
d'allumer allez tuez-moi appuyez sur la
gâchette vous n'avez même pas les couilles
pour vous faire ça ce n'est jamais  sois en sécurité tu
ne pourras jamais revenir bien
oh nous allons  queue
tu peux courir mais tu ne peux pas te cacher
c'est ainsi que le jeu se joue